und in berlin wird heute in wenigen
minuten darüber beraten ob ähnliche
verschärfungen auch bei uns dann in der
hauptstadt drohen
und bei mir im studio ist jetzt frank
ochse bildstocks und verbraucherexperte
schön dass du da bist palazzi na ja wir
haben es gehört jens spahn geht also
grundsätzlich von reisen ins ausland ab
wie siehst du das ist ungefährlich jetzt
noch ins ausland zu verreisen gerade mit
hinblick auf die ferien
also ich würde mich wirklich strikt
daran halten was ist wirklich ein
risikogebiet und welches nicht es gibt
ja diverse länder zum beispiel italien
oder griechenland da kann man aus meiner
sicht gefahrlos hinreisen
aber was hier einsparen meint natürlich
es lockt natürlich immer mallorca aber
es ist halt wirklich sehr sehr schwierig
da die infektionszahlen steigen und das
ist natürlich auch ein riesiges problem
erstens beim thema infektion und
außerdem werden ja auch die quarantäne
regeln zum ersten zehnten massiv
verschärft das heißt also dann müsste
ich mit theoretisch vielleicht sogar bis
zu fünf tagen zusätzlichen urlaub nehmen
das lohnt sich nicht davon kann ich
wirklich nur abraten
und was ist denn jetzt wenn man so ein
bisschen verunsichert ist von der
aussage von jens spahn hat aber
eigentlich schon was gebucht für die
herbstferien zum beispiel kann man dann
auch irgendwie zurücktreten und sich das
geld dann auch wieder
ja das ist natürlich schwierig weil
natürlich angst ist immer ganz
schlechter berater hatte ich muss gucken
was ich gemacht habe ist es eine
pauschalreise und das ziel landwirt
risikogebiet dann wird die in den
allermeisten fällen sowieso abgesagt ich
bekomme mein geld zurück
anders ist es wenn ich einen flug und
hotel separat gebucht habe da bin ich
auf die kulanz der anbieter angewiesen
also bei airlines kann man natürlich
dann umbuchen zeit auch ins nächste jahr
das ist dann teilweise sogar kostenlos
bei hotels muss ich halt schauen was ich
gebucht habe ist es eine eine stunde rad
oder muss ich dann am besten vielleicht
sogar das hotel verfallen lassen im
schlimmsten fall bleibe ich natürlich
dann auf dem schaden sitzen
aber das heißt die gute nachricht wenn
jetzt ein land spontan zum risikogebiet
erklärt wird bekomme ich mein geld
wieder absolut und sogar wenn du dort
vor ort bist ist das sowieso auch gar
kein problem weil du bist ja völlig
unverschuldet in diese lage geraten auch
da würdest du natürlich wenn du früher
abreißt den rest des urlaubs dann wieder
ausgezahlt bekommen dankeschön frank
ochse mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schau dir das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren